Welcome back everyone this will be my brand
new thor love and thunder video for no
god of the symbiotes and all the eternal's
easter eggs them setting up much bigger cosmic
things in the background i've been getting
a lot of questions about the null character
in general because he's so big for the gore
of the god butcher and necrosword storyline
so if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos marvel comic-con
is starting next week there's going to be so many
trailers that they're bringing for everything i'll
try to do as many videos as possible we're
supposed to get a black panther 2 trailer
they're bringing what if season 2 we might get
an x-men 97 trailer for the x-men revival series
and that's just the beginning we'll probably get
some teasers for secret wars they did say that
they would make a bunch of big reveals about
the direction of marvel phase four and they
just been setting up time runs out secret wars
and we know about a lot of the movies that are
coming in marvel phase four already that they've
announced but that are a couple years away still
careful for spoilers for thor love and thunder
if you haven't seen the movie yet but a lot of
you have been asking how gore the necrosword are
connected to no god of the symbiotes because in
the comics they are deeply connected originally
the necrosword was created as a piece of himself
it's the primal symbiote like the very first
symbiote you can actually wield it and control
all other symbiotes this is a big connection
to the venom character in the venom mythology
because they have this big sony and marvel sharing
deal for the spider-man character and all these
spider-man spin-offs that sony's doing on its own
they've been trying to set up their own version
of avengers infinity war and avengers end game
that they can spin up to like a really universe
spanning story very cosmic story kind of like what
marvel is doing over in the mcu side of things
right now there was an actual deleted scene during
venom lutheran carnage where they talk about no it
starts to set the character up it's a little
bit raw but this is it this is where we begin
we'll make them pay for what they did to us all
humans are pestilence oh god why look to god when
you have him right here the father of all but
technically isn't eddie brock's monster your
father a new breed wait i will eat your face sorry
sorry those who speak of humanity we say only our
offspring survive we can create a new race part
human parts symbiote that will rule the world
an unholy trinity they're trying to set up a
whole bunch of things with that scene like the
whole idea that the carnage symbiote is going
to give birth to the toxin symbiote eventually
but also null god of the symbiotes like there is
an actual god of the symbiotes that they worship
making the connection back to thor love and
thunder gore in the necrosword so in the movie at
the beginning when gore sees the previous wielder
of the necrosword he's been killed by gore's gods
but he's covered all in black then the necrosword
calls to him you hear these voices speaking to him
from the sword and telling him all these details
about how to find eternity telling him to kill the
gods what's happening there is that the necrosword
is the primal symbiote is basically null himself
speaking to him telling him what to do just
like the venom symbiote does with eddie during
the venom movies all the symbiotes have their own
consciousness the klyntar race but the difference
with the necrosword is that it's called the primal
symbiote because it's the very first one it's
literally a piece of knull's body that he used
to slaughter all the most powerful beings after
the big bang in creation of the universe nola is
a cosmic being like a cosmic god level being who
existed in the void of nothingness before the
big bang he hates creation in everything that
came after like all living beings that came
after the big bang so he essentially wants to
return the universe back to nothingness back to
the void it's kind of like what the dark elves
were doing during thor love and thunder a little
while ago they made a much bigger connection with
thor in the comics too like thor encountered
the primal symbiote a couple different times
it's just that it's most notable story is the
origin of the necrosword for instance the dead
celestial that we see in guardians of the galaxy
nowhere it's like the head of a dead celestial
that belongs to jamiah the analyzer he is a
celestial who was killed by the necrosword
essentially chopping his head off that's where
that head came from because right after creation
the only things for noel to attack were basically
the celestials like cosmic entities did exist but
really were the celestials that existed there as
physical beings usually the cosmic entities exist
in alternate planes of existence like alternate
dimensions that's why they had to use the bifrost
to get to actual eternity's consciousness they
had to travel to a little pocket dimension to
get to where it actually exists it's not like if
you had a regular spaceship you could just use
it to fly to eternity in part of the universe
but the reason why null himself isn't running
around in the mcu right now is because after he
created the primal symbiote eventually it spawned
and created other regular symbiotes and then all
those symbiotes banded together to trap him for
all eternity but after that the primal symbiote
still existed the necrosword still existed people
could use it eventually gore found it and started
using it to kill all these gods that's why he was
able to do it why it was so powerful because
it's basically the piece of this cosmic being
in the eternals movie in the loki series we get
a little bit of history from this early period
in the mcu like right around when the big bang is
happening irishman the judge tells the story about
how he's the prime celestial the thing that came
before the universe and created the first galaxy
the first sun but the really interesting thing
they just did in thor love and thunder some of
you have also asked me about this if you watch
closely towards the end of the movie when they're
in that hall with all the cosmic entities one
of them that crumbles like this big head of a
celestial is actually the prime celestial the true
prime celestial it's also called the one above
all but it's not meant to be like the one true
god one above all like there are two different
things in marvel comics that are called the one
above all so people confuse them all the time
this one is just the true prime celestial so
airshim the judge is just the leader of the
current version of the celestial host this one was
the leader of the original first celestial host so
which is more evidence that airship the judge was
also lying about the true origin of the universe
in the eternals movie you find out he was lying
about a lot of things to the eternals it makes
sense that he'd be lying about other stuff too
but for instance the necrosword in the movie is
said to come from the shadow realm gore uses the
shadow room to travel around he commands all these
shadow beasts it seems like they were trying to
do a lot of the null backstory and connections
without literally coming out and mentioning the
name null like the shadow demons in the shadow
realm are very much in the vein of null without
them coming right out and saying it for instance
the shadow realm is kind of like the void from
before the universe existed in the shadow demons
look and act just like symbiotes in her control
by the necrosword the same way that the primal
symbiote controls all other symbiotes so you
can see sony is just trying to tie things to
marvel as much as possible marvel has big cosmic
plans with what's happening in marvel phase four
mostly secret wars plans but sony also wants to
have their own version of something on that level
and that's basically null because they control
the spider-man rights and they're basically
trying to create a spider-man type of universe on
their side of things if it wasn't clear they've
already explained that the venom movies in the
morbius movie both happen on the same planet and
now they have the madame web movie and obviously
there are a lot of multiverse connections in that
she'll also probably be on that same earth that
venom comes from one of the reasons why i think
they avoided saying noel's name in thor love and
thunder is one just because they chopped the movie
down to two hours which apparently was a mandate
that was given to taikobatiti by disney and marvel
like that's why there are so many deleted
scenes i already did a separate video about
all the biggest deleted scenes there are a lot of
them like this could have been a four hour movie
also during venom let the beat carnage in the post
credit scene the venom symbiote sounds like it's
getting ready to tell eddie about all this history
behind the origin of the klyntar race and null god
of the symbiotes when it tells him about revealing
80 billion years of history it's talking about
across time and space so it's talking about
this grand history but also existing across
the multiverse and that was sort of meant to set
up what was happening with spiderman no way home
with all the different versions of spider-man like
toby maguire spider-man andrew garfield spider-man
and tom hall of spider-man all from different
universes that's also the reason why eddie
brock's venom symbiote from his universe
recognized tom hall and spider-man saying
that guy because even though he didn't know tom
holland until jane jonah jameson pointed him out
he remembered a version of spider-man because the
hive memories that he was accessing were from the
topher grace's version of venom from a different
universe so he remembered that guy the spider-man
guy and if you watch a lot of the spider-man
news after venom let there be carnage came out
and after spider-man no way home came out all the
actors were talking about eventually doing a big
venom spider-man crossover there was just a lot of
questions about which version of spider-man they
were going to use but the way that tom holland
and tom hardy talked about it it was going to be
their two versions of the characters crossing over
with each other at some point and it was going to
happen on the sony side of things according
to kevin feige like sony was going to handle
whatever that spider-man versus venom movie was
going to be they already confirmed they're making
venom 3 but i think that's mostly going to be a
toxin movie just based on the things that they
set up during venomous carnage i think all the
larger cosmic stuff all the null god of symbiote
stuff all those deleted scenes are for something
way further down the line something way bigger
it's kind of like them setting up doctor strange
three with the clia post credit scene in doctor
strange too but also kind of trying to set up
secret wars i know there are a lot of questions
with the way marvel's been doing a lot of
its recent post-credits scenes like what
are they setting up here is this secret wars is
there other stuff they're setting up here too
the answer is always yes always setting up the
next movie for this one particular character but
also setting up something way bigger down the line
that's why comic con next week is so important as
i'm posting this video because yes we will get the
black panther 2 trailer but kevin feige has said
that they will reveal more concrete plans about
what the actual road map is going to be like we
all have theories about the way that secret wars
is going to go down eventually but we don't know
exactly how the road map is going to go so i'll
do as many marvel phase 4 videos and trailer
videos as possible next week make sure you have
alerts enabled for my channel so you don't miss
any of that and if you have any questions about
what's going on with null in the greater scheme
of things at sony and marvel just write it
below in the comments there's only room for
like a couple big things the next couple of
years but obviously they're trying to set up
like a billion things in the background everyone
click here for my brand new loki season 2 first
look video in easter eggs and click here for
my brand new mandalorian season 3 trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!